there's a lot of great people on both
sides lots of great people on both sides
I know Hario he a great person he
couldn't vote for me at the time now he
can vote for me once he gets out I love
snoopd Double J great person do you love
Death Row
Records I love death excuse me excuse me
excuse me fakeess fakeess they're trying
to give me
the that's great excuse me excuse me
fake reviews fake reviews fake reviews
they tried to give me the virus
I beat the virus say they Tred to they
they tried to get the vir like who is
they Trump gave what I think was
probably one of the greatest speeches of
world leader given you know it's got to
be up there with like Churchill
Gettysburg Address is the night the
United States killed the leader of Isis
Trump comes out of the Situation Room at
like midnight in the white house and he
walks down that [__] tunnel like he's
he gives a press conference like he's
given a postgame NBA just goes Abu car
outbag daddy is dead he died like a dog
and
[__] I didn't change one word of that
that's what he opened with and then he
did 40 minutes the speech is 40 minutes
the meanest [__] talk you've ever heard
in front of the whole world
Abu we could hear him crying I said Abu
don't cry AB let me tell you something
Abu cried he cried quite a bit I
wouldn't have cried
Cry Baby Back daddy that's what we were
all
calling I have not uh had an inperson
interview with the former president if I
did I would ask him what would you ask
look at look at this smirk what are you
going to ask um did you know they were
going to storm the capital and does that
make you a party to an insc what you see
what he's doing do all these people
watching and what you're doing it's so
disgusting and and you know that because
there was no storming there was no
storming okay a lot of people were say
they're going to go we're going to send
them home like a dog we're going to send
them home back to China and that's what
they did it's pretty uncanny well it's
very uncanny but what's not uncanny is
you're saying we sent them there which
totally is not true thank you very much
China cuz Donald Trump gave the illusion
that he was speaking truth to power and
now you got all these conserv fake news
everything is a fake news I don't care
fake news everywhere this is a very good
very good podcast brilliant idiots I'm a
brilliant
idiot I'm just an idiot no I'm not an
idiot I'm brilliant you guys are the
idiots everything's fake charlam your
name is not really charlam that is very
true fake news piece of [__] this is a
piece of [__] podcast you should be very
embarrassed we Trump off Trump
off very good there's a lot of guys
doing uh lot of people doing me you're a
very good
impersonator he's nice at it it's not
bad Jo D Roo what a
pig disgusting pigy I would love to put
the country on your shoulders but Joe it
might slide
off I'm a very good comedian I could be
a comedian a lot of guys a lot of guys
say Joe's built like a worm I don't say
that but Joe is built like a worm
he looks like the Men in Black aliens
grew
up Mr Trump this leaked audio showed you
saying um you know I can't I can't quite
say it on live television um but
basically uh you said you wanted to to
grab them by the
[__] Trump two more minutes the thing
about the
blacks
is that they're killing each
other he hasn't released his tax returns
which means he's either not that rich
not that charitable or he's never paid
taxes in his life
warmer
Siri how about
kisis this a
Blackberry big beautiful boobs and
buildings big beautiful boobs and
buildings big boobs and buildings that's
the same thing as Obamacare and if you
repeal it 20 million people will lose
their health insurance I mean people
could die Listen sweetheart I'm about to
be president world going to die next
question your main job here is to go in
rooms before me to make sure there's no
static
electricity don't go in there it's not
safe well done
Peter
Scooby-Doo Scooby
dooo Scooby-Doo they call him Scooby-Doo
they call show Scooby scoy do but Scooby
doesn't do anything Scooby is not
involved at the time Scooby's not even
involved he's just a bystander it's one
of the worst deals we've ever had to
call the show Scooby-Doo and then not
deliver on Scooby-Doo we this not a show
about a dog sniffing its ass okay they
should call the
show Velma why don't they call the show
Velma VMA is the one doing everything
Fred DNE they're just over there porking
in the corner they're not they're not
doing anything the making out being
unhelpful okay Fred just drives Fred's
just a driver he doesn't drive the plant
and he doesn't drive the mystery and he
doesn't solve the mystery he just moves
the van from place to place a to B and
it's a very unhelpful thing but in terms
of trump I have to stand do you mind
sure so when he stands he stands like
this he has no center of gravity he is
that's why he's like always leaning on
people so he leans like this and then
you have to accentuate the mouth bring
the mouth forward and then bring in in
the arms this is the key the arms I'll
do now do the whole thing we're we're
doing so well so unbelievable now
Michael first off individual one isn't
me okay that's an individual and he's
one guy he's one guy we don't know who
he is and Michael was talking to him I
don't know who he is I'll never know him
no matter how hard I stare into the
mirror I'll never know him I'll never
really know him Melania says she knows
him it's exactly how he drink water
that's
exactly like a dove drinking from a
small
pond my support of Bill O'Reilly was
wrong insensitive and totally
[Applause]
stupid
jilani into a I just he's just a ragd
doll at this point just a rag doll he
looks like a seal getting tossed around
by orca it's awful awful and every time
they do it he just his eyes just get so
big I've never seen big eyes like the
eyes are huge and it was interesting
halfway through the sketch he looks
around and goes is this funny is this
good is everybody it was it was on the
fox pregame at that like is that is this
good and everybody yes Mr Trump
Fantastic Mr Trump was great Mr Trump
and I was like wait wait wait wait does
anybody ever say something's not good
he's like no Franken that's part of the
problem I can't get real answers so I
like oh he gets it that was one of those
moments for me but for Trump he's an
Entertainer oh yeah and in the debates
you can't beat him in a debate I talk
about this in my act because he argues
like a 5-year-old it's impossible
they're like Donald you can't do that oh
yeah well you're a duty head you're the
stupidest stupid face I've ever seen in
my entire life and I've seen a lot of
stupid people listen listen the reason
I'm beating everybody I don't even have
to look at anything I can close my eyes
and I'm actually seeing myself it's an
outof Body Experience where I'm actually
inside my body twice and it sounds weird
but it's actually happening right now I
could tell by the way I'm I'm not even
going to have a I'm not even going to
have a sidekick that's what I call the
vice president as a sidekick I'm not
going to have a sidekick I'm just going
to have a puppet handed it's going to be
me it's going to be puppet Donald Trump
it'll be tremendous and we'll be talking
to each other the entire time look at
this guy great great great great great
isn't he doing fantastic
I got to say you're doing a great job in
fact I think the show just got better by
about 2 billion
per. in fact they just told me Donald
other Donald they just told me this very
interesting that now that I'm here this
is actually the best monologue in SNL
history can you believe that pretty
great yeah that's pretty good that's
pretty good oh look at
this
you think you're this terrific
person you think you're this you think
you're that
and you're being very naive and quite
frankly you're
fired